change lives yet mean a jalar these
organizations I be instated organization
is awesome change the world where the
GSB is going to have the biggest impact
is changing the organization's I'm going
to work with I used to think a lot of
leadership as having charisma and strong
will and that's helpful but far far from
sufficient it's really about empathy and
understanding the people you're trying
to lead organizations need individuals
who take initiative who are creative who
can problem solve change organization
company so soon change organizations
they change organizations the world in
which our students are going to manage
is changing at an increasingly rapid
rate we equip our students with the
ability to understand global context of
management we require that every single
student go to a country where they did
not grow up and where they're not that
significant work experience it helps you
get out of the classroom and into the
real world into a room with somebody
who's an expert in the field and
actually being able to understand how do
you build an oil well in Brazil how do
you build a new company in Brazil that's
experience that you can't get in the
classroom you don't only get what you
should do but I'll see you get ideas on
how to do it and you remember the kind
of real life in fact that you can have
on people and organizations no matter
how much we talk about a country it's a
completely different thing to actually
come to a country I was a leader on a
global study trip to Kenya new one there
we met with President Kagame the person
for Wonder don't about more the former
president of Kenya we might be head of
marketing available a meeting with
beyond cattle we're meeting with
Charlotte he'd ask ami tambien China
series of equity bank Kenya Airways
today we are meeting with mr. lot of
Industry and Commerce and
important person in the whole health
instructor he's also Stanford GSB alum
why I think the GSP is amazing
environment it is so people centric in
his approach it was a wonderful
experience of two years I'm the one have
some experiences that I've had in like
some of the lessons learned from GSP
alums are amazing the key takeaways that
they took from Stanford and how they're
able to implement them I mean change
organizations the way I'm doing it is to
you know be a female at the stroll at
this level to have the confidence to
speak my voice tonight we well visitor
it's a lot of just alumnus in Shanghai
from our industries Simeon our nights
are very warm-hearted to give us a
greater career device we require that on
every study trip at least one faculty
member joins the students when the
faculty come on these trips we develop
that first-hand knowledge about these
international economies see the way
local business leaders are responding to
the particular environment they find
themselves in we can bring that
experience directly into the classroom
and say look we've spoken with these
business leaders the professor's offer
insights that help you quickly get to
sort of the root issues of what we're
looking at but really helps learning
experience change organizations change
of an ica stones Miller sure when it's
all done we've got organized change
organizations the more you here
people about how they do things what
they think is important you begin to get
a sense of what is my leadership style
what are the things that said resonating
with me we just show the portray that
are out there yes what at 28 29 you can
come and be a VP you can work with CEO
the next step for you to for you is to
be in a senior leadership and then
change organizations what I've learned
here on leadership won't change is going
to be hugely valuable to me in the next
three to five years of my career and
obviously far beyond that